[ YouTube Learning ]
As a teacher, you have a lot of work to do,
and a lot of content to deliver.
In this video, I will take you on a journey
right from the start where you get your time table
or your learning objective,
to how you could use different Google Classroom tools
to teach your students online
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
As a teacher, assume that I have to teach
the following concept to my students.
And there are additional details given as well.
Pause the video, take a moment
and go through the text you see on the screen
Now I have to think of 3 broad things.
1st,
What is it that my students need to know in advance;
2nd, what is it that I
will teach during the live class,
and third,
How is it that I will check for their understanding.
As simple as that!
So how will I begin?
I create a class….
fill in the required details…
and click on create...
It will get us to this screen!
Please note that some teachers may
create a class differently.
Here I've created one Google Classroom class
to teach one subject to one class.
As a teacher it depends on what you're comfortable
with and what your school requests you to do.
If you remember,
the name of the chapter was Quadrilaterals.
So let me go to the ClassWork section,
click on create,
and create the topic called Quadrilaterals.
Now this becomes a chapter within my class!
Now let me go back to the stream section of my class.
Once my class is created,
I will share the Class code you see here
with my students.
My students will then use the Join Class option
to enter the code and join my class.
Maybe I could first make an announcement for
the students about the live class by posting
it on the Stream like this…
or I could also send out an email to all my students
by going to the People Section.
Before I start communicating with my students, it's
important that I have done my homework as a teacher.
It’s always a good idea to keep your presentations,
files, images, and questions ready.
But where could I store these files
without the risk of losing them?
The answer is Google Drive!
Wait, What is that?
Let me quickly explain.
It’s a place where we can store our files.
And the files are not stored on our local machine
or laptop here
It’s stored on remote servers,
which is a much safer option,
and we can access it whenever we feel like.
The data there is completely safe
and no one can really access our files unless we give
anyone the permission to access them!
But…
How do I access Google Drive in Google Classroom?
All I will do is go to the Classwork section,
and here I can see the Class Drive Folder button.
Let me click on it.
This space I am seeing here is where I can save my files
and access them whenever I wish to.
If I go to Classroom here,
I will see folders for all the classes I am managing
or the ones that I had managed before.
Let me get into the current class folder.
Now how do I Add files here?
After I use the right-click option,
there are 2 things I can do.
One, I could also ADD my files or folders here
by simply using the Upload options.
This will allow me to upload my existing files
from my machine to this folder.
It’s as easy as that.
And second,
I could directly CREATE files
by using any of the other options.
I could create a Google Doc,
a Google Slides Presentation,
or even a Google Form for quizzes.
And don’t worry;
my students will NOT have access to this folder,
unless I give it to them.
Once I have all the files ready
for my pre-class and post-class work,
I am now ready to begin
using the Google Classroom tools to teach my students.
And I don’t have to worry as I can
always Add or Remove more files on the go!
At this point, I have most of my files ready
in my Class Drive Folder.
Some preclass files and some postclass files.
Now I have done most of my background work!
Let us go back to our class in Google Classroom.
By clicking on Create,
I am ready to share some material with my students.
I enter the title and the description,
and then give students access to the relevant
files I have created.
We click on Add, and then go to Google Drive!
Now, this is interesting!
In the recent tab, I will be able to see which files
I recently created or uploaded to Google Drive.
If it’s something I created recently,
it will be very easy to select one from here.
But there’s an even better way.
If I remember the name of my file,
I could just SEARCH for it here,
and select from the dropdown.
Let me select one now.
To add another file, I go to Add again,
And alternatively, I could go to MyDrive,
then to my class, and then select the file.
You will see it here along with the previous one.
If I have not kept the files ready,
I could also create it on the go by clicking on ‘Create’
and then selecting the most appropriate option!
Now I am almost ready to post this and
share it with my students.
I will just select the relevant topic
and click on Post.
Now the background knowledge topics
are ready for my students.
I’ve now covered what students need to know in
advance, that is BEFORE my live class.
In the next video,
I will show you how I will use different tools
in Google Classroom to teach during a live class,
and also how we could check for
the understanding of our students
See you there!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]